[Music]
gun violence and opioids are not the
only epidemics facing this country
another one is mass incarceration the
united states locks up more people per
capita
than any other country in the entire
world according to the nonprofit prison
policy initiative
more than 2 million people are
incarcerated on any given day
and that's just where the vicious cycle
begins recidivism rates show that within
three years of release 68 percent of
prisoners
are rearrested so when we talk about the
idea
of mass incarceration and this big vast
topic
much of the focus usually is on the
person who is incarcerated and
in prison but what about the loved ones
on the outside those left
behind the 2018 critically acclaimed
film blind spotting focused on
a parolee within three with with three
days left on his sentence
now there's a tv spin-off based on that
really
incredible film but the tv show centers
around the families
of those incarcerated and this show has
a strong
female focused storyline which you know
that's my jam
in the show ashley's longtime partner is
in prison
and she is left to raise and protect
their son from a growing crisis
of police brutality grammy an emmy
award-winning actress jasmine cephas
jones
plays ashley and she joins me now and
i'm so excited
to have you here today so thank you so
much for taking the time
thank you so much for having me
so i love this show and i love it
because when a show is built around the
women
characters and it's not sort of like
you're doing something in response to
whatever the man is doing
um that's my jam so in this show
we're talking about an issue that we've
seen in other shows mass incarceration
is an issue we talk about
but it's never focused on the prisoners
loved ones the incarcerated person's
family why is it so important important
to you
that this show focuses on ashley's
perspective
i think it's really important to show
that
you know like you said the prison system
affects everyone involved and that is
including the families left behind
um to show how strong
a family can be to to support each other
the friendships the female friendships
um you know we see so many stories of
the prisoners
but you know this the it also affects
everybody outside that
is involved and also continues on also
with you know
um benjamin um earl turner's character
um he plays earl and you know he's on
probation and it
and it's still he's out of prison but it
still haunts him
after he's after he's out and it's hard
for him
to to live in this world
out you know outside of prison so um i
just think
it's it's an it's a it's a perspective
that i think um is
interesting for people to find out more
about
and to get more of an understanding that
it's not just
inside these prison walls it affects all
the loved ones that
that are involved and trickles down
um and you know how they deal with that
trauma how they deal with that
depression
all of that is is incredibly powerful
and i think that comes through
in the show um but one of the things
about the show that i love is that it's
unlike anything else like it's
about serious issues and it's funny
but then i'm like not sure if i'm
supposed to be laughing sometimes
and i'm like this is ridiculous and
scary but and disturbing but also
hilarious and beautiful
um can you talk about just the tone of
the show because i think it's so
unique and original there's spoken word
where you're talking
you're breaking that fourth wall there's
choreography um
and it's so oakland and that comes
across in every single frame so just
talk about how all of that comes
together and why
it's it's a unique portrayal of that
family experience on the outside of a
prison that you were talking about
i'm so proud of the show and the way
we handle the comedy and also you know
the important issues that we talk about
in the show it is entertaining and
you know you are supposed to laugh and
but i think that's also kind of
the reality of life you know people
people laugh through their trauma people
deal with traumas in so many different
ways
and you know i my it follows my
character ashley and she goes into
these heightened verse sequences and
you know i had to kind of analyze them
almost like shakespearean monologues
where she really opens up
you know with the audience it's her most
honest and truest self and then
you know you have the choreography in
the show which is almost like
a greek chorus in a play and
you know they're basically dancing our
feelings and
showing an another way another creative
way to express
what is happening in the scene um
and kind of you know this this haunting
idea of the prison system and that it
never leaves you
once you are involved with it in some
sort of way shape or form and i think
you know we are
us as actors we are like these emotional
vessels to really show the humanity
of of what happens and and you know all
of these feelings that we have that are
complicated and complex and especially
through
you know the female point of view um
um to show that my my character ashley
she is
she's an amazing mother she's a strong
mother she'll do anything for her family
but she'll also break down you know
or track a hotel room or you know um
break the fourth knowledge where how
she's feeling with the audience and
that is so human and such a beautiful
way to
to show the complexities of of what
happens to these people and you know in
these situations
it's so funny that you say that you have
to sort of find the comedy
in the trauma because as i sit here in
the middle of this pandemic
i have often asked myself the question
like i have never lived through a
pandemic before
but like when i i see a funny meme about
the pandemic or
or even like the insurrection i'm like i
wonder if people
in history made funny memes and jokes
about sort of the trauma they were
experiencing
how have you been processing what
what you were all going through i mean
you're making incredible art
during one of i think for everyone no
matter what you do
the weirdest time in history
um honestly every day is different
you know i really can't sit here and and
be like i do this
all the time because i don't it changes
you know i'm
i'm grateful and and so thankful that
i've been able to work in this pandemic
and
and give people some sort of
entertainment and another world to
escape to
i like to watch you know a lot of
movies and tvs to to escape
and and try to have you know spend time
if i can with my loved ones and my
friends as much as possible
you know it's really this pandemic has
shown me the you know the value and how
important relationships
are you know especially at the beginning
when
when we were taken or that was taken
away from us you know i didn't know when
i was gonna
be able to see my mom or my dad you know
next i
i had no idea so you know every day is
different i think we all handle it
in many different ways some more
responsible than others
um but it's it's a day-by-day process
you and your dad made history by being
the first
father-daughter duo to win emmys in the
same year and you're halfway to egot
already and you're only 32. so
what what is your like goal sheet look
like
at this point what are you striving for
oh man i you know i i never want to put
myself in a box there's
there's so much that i want to do i i
just went away for a week
a week and wrote a whole album
um i want to focus on my music at the
moment
um i'm i'd love to
continue to produce and and create my
own material i have a bunch of ideas and
and stuff that i've already been working
on
for other tv shows and movies that i
want to create
so i think it's kind of endless and you
know whatever
keeps pushing me as an artist and keeps
challenging me
you know that's that's what i want to do
i never want to fully feel comfortable
i love that it's like being an artist
there's just limitless potential you
just
you keep going and you keep pushing um
and you keep
creating it's beautiful jasmine c fish
jones thank you so much for taking the
time
and congratulations on the show it's
really really um
original and and fascinating and i hope
people check it out
thank you so much thank you for having
me